tommy et marie jacques sont en
patrouille au parc de la frayère à
boucherville
il veille à la conservation des milieux
naturels dans la région c'était même à
vocation depuis près de 20 ans et
environnementalistes 1000 et surtout
pour la protection de l'habitat de la
rainette faux grillon
une espèce menacée la rainette faux
grillon présentement dans g aurier il se
porte très mal
lorsqu'on a commencé en 2003 on avait
déjà perdu 90% des effectifs de la
grille puis des pylones a perdu un autre
30 à 40% c'est justement pour protéger
l'habitat de la reinette et d'autres
milieux naturels que la communauté
métropolitaine de montréal adopte un
règlement qui interdira tout travaux ou
construction à ces endroits au nom de la
lutte contre les changements climatiques
c'est maintenant que ça que ça se passe
j'ai envie de vous dire qu'on n'a pas le
temps miezis actuellement environ 10 %
du territoire du grand montréal est
protégée en y ajoutant ses milieux
terrestres humide et l'habitat de la
rainette faux grillon cette proportion
passerait à plus de 22 % soit
l'équivalent de la superficie de l'île
de montréal c'est énorme c'est un geste
qui est important je pense que c'est une
initiative qui est très cohérente avec
la science qui est nécessaire mais
certains milieux naturels ont déjà été
détruits comme le marais darveau de
longueuil remblayer par le canadien
national malheureusement scène hip hop
possible de rétablir le milieu pourrait
garantir le retour de la rainette faux
grillon donc c'est très déplorable des
tortues sont juste une heure pas très
loin des endroits comme celui ci seront
dorénavant protégé majal on parle de
plusieurs milliers d'hectares qui vont
être protégé par se régale donc c'est
quelque chose de vraiment qu'on
attendait depuis très longtemps un peu
de répit pour les espèces qui vivent
donc ce règlement adopté par la
communauté métropolitaine de montréal
entrera en vigueur dès son approbation
par le gouvernement du québec la
ministre des affaires municipales aura
60 jours pour décider de l'approuver ou
non et si sébastien desrosiers radio
canada longueuil